[Music]
thank you
Hello friends and thank you for joining
us here in I'd like to know this one of
one of our favorite programs as we can
share and discuss the questions that you
send to us I Am David Salazar and I'm
delighted to be able to present to you
today's program with two distinguished
guests to my left Pastor Stephen Bohr
president of Secrets and sealed thank
you Pastor for joining us my pleasure
it's a blessing to have you and to my
right Pastor C.A Murray thank you for
joining us Pastor is a blessing to have
you here with us once again it's always
good to have the family together to
discuss the word of God Amen and we are
certainly interested in discussing the
word of God with you remember you can
send your questions your inquiries to
this following address TV at some
tv.org that is TV at
samtv.org I pray that you will be able
to send your questions and remember that
there are some questions that we have
already answered so there is a chance
your question may be already answered
and we will reply to you letting you
know where you can watch the episode
that will answer the question that you
have in mind now with that said let us
start today's presentation program
discussing the questions that we have
today by asking Pastor Ward to pray for
us as we open the program
let's pray Father in heaven we see
through a glass Darkly now
we have so many questions that we try to
answer but we're not able
but we thank you that in your word many
of the questions we have do find an
answer
and we thank you for that and we ask
that as we begin this program that your
holy spirit will be with us to Enlighten
our minds to understand your word that
you will also Enlighten the minds of
those who are watching this program we
ask that you will prepare a place for us
when we arrive in heaven and every
question that we ever had will be
answered by Jesus himself we look
forward to that day and we ask that this
in his name amen amen amen
well as we start today's program we do
we have a question that came to us in
regards to the godhead and we want to
allow their friend Javen to understand
that we will send you a reply via email
letting you know where we can or we have
answered this question is really an
extensive question that has been
answered before we don't want to take
more time and answer the same thing so
we want to just uh encourage you to to
receive watch your email and we you will
receive the the instructions or the link
to the program where we have answered
the question that you have for us now
with that in mind let's start with a
question that comes to someone from
South Africa hendrika and the question
is in regards to uh something that we
have I don't know if we have answered
before but we'll answer it again just in
case if we haven't in the past this
question is the following the Bible
describes clean and unclean animals and
fish and also some birds the Bible does
mention unclean Birds but does not give
distinct differences as for animals and
fish so the question is why is it that
the Bible does not give this defined
differences distinct differences for for
birds as it does for fish and animals
land animals I think that you know in
the in the question here as it's written
there's a word that if you eliminate the
word it makes a lot more sense the Bible
does mention unclean Birds
but does uh the the Bible does mention
unclean birds in other words gives a
list of unclean Birds but does give
eliminate the word not okay but does
give distinct differences as for animals
and fish in other words for animals and
fish it tells which ones you can eat or
not eat by not giving a list right but
as far as Birds is concerned it doesn't
give you any characteristics necessarily
it simply gives you a list of birds that
you can't eat for example
um fins and scales that's that's a
category you know a split hoof you know
category but we don't have that kind of
thing
that kind of thing so so it doesn't give
the truth is when you're studying the
word of God some of the gold is lying
pretty near the surface
some of the gold you got to dig a little
bit right you know you got to dig down
and and and uh think your way through
some of this stuff but there is there is
an answer there is a reason there's a
methodology to the way the Bible
explains things but all of the gold is
not lying on the surface sometimes you
got to dig down and reason your way
through things and that is not not meant
to be a a put down of edrico but um we
need to read the word of God but we also
need to study the word of God Amen you
know the let me just read some of the
list of the birds that are mentioned
um The Raven I don't know anybody who
eats Ravens the kinds scary the Falcon
right the seagull the hawk The Little
Owl the Fishel owl the screech owl the
white owl uh the carrion vulture uh the
Heron uh the bat
uh you know
all of those
are clearly just if you use your reason
unclean
but it doesn't mean anything mention
anything about chickens and you know
other birds that that don't feed other
birds or eat refuse or dead carcasses
yes and so what the Bible does is it
gives a list of birds that existed at
that time uh which are birds of prey and
carrion and uh and so you're supposed to
say you know is this bird a bird that we
should eat or that we should not eat and
by the way it's best not to eat any bird
yeah no they especially nowadays
but you know I suppose that they that
you my pastor mentioned in the bible
there there is a list that tells you
what not to eat and clearly kind of
gives it the guideline of what birds we
should abstain from but I have never had
you know by choice uh eating animals so
I I I don't have to really worry about
them at least anymore so we encourage
you to to Really perhaps choose the best
and the healthiest food available
whatever you know if you you think about
vultures buzzards uh crows Ravens that
eat not only Dead uh flesh but Rotting
Flesh you know they they eat their
systems are so constructed that they can
eat
filthy Rotting Flesh and and they're
fine now there's no way
you can cook something like that and and
put it in your body and not have you
know the the bird is so constituted it
can do that we're not constituted that
way absolutely so there's no inner World
you'd want to you'd want to want to do
that uh because you're that's going to
be against you uh sooner or later amen
and by the way the prescriptions that
are given in Leviticus 11 and
Deuteronomy 14. if you read carefully
they are not part of the ceremonial law
[Music]
there is no ritual law involved in these
it has to do with your health absolutely
absolutely and we have to be careful
with how even people that eat clean
needs to follow the principles that are
there established yeah we can we can
never pray and Lord bless this which
thou Hast cursed
exactly
be very careful with that the timing is
though near that or has come that we are
to really as of Spain from as much as
possible from animal
eating as possible as according to the
superior prophecy as well amen so let's
continue with the next question that
comes from Michael and we don't know the
location of the square of where he's
from we do like you to remember those
that send the questions to uh we like to
know where you're from if that's
something you can share we will
definitely appreciate that as well the
question is the following I've been
following your presentations on secrets
and seal for quite some time now and I
have to say my knowledge and
understanding of the Bible have been
greatly enriched may God bless your
ministry and give you long and healthy
lives thank you for that uh continuing
says isaf 40 26 the New Living
Translation says look up in the heavens
who created all the stars he brings them
out like an army one after another
calling each by its name because of his
great power and incomparable strength
not a single one is missing so my
question in line with this is how would
you go about explaining to a person who
believes in evolutionary science and the
Big Bang Theory that this verse is true
from the Bible
I say this because scientists claim to
have evidence of black holes and
extremely chaotic events in the universe
of exploding stars and if scientists
have gotten some basic things right
about the universe how can one go about
arguing against these ideas
surely a universe created by God has no
place for random and chance occurrences
kindly shared answer from the Bible or
Spirit prophecy we can thanks in advance
so gentlemen this is an interesting
question in regards to this verse in
Isaiah 40 26. there's no evidence
whatsoever
that um
you know that the explosion of stars
to create many other stars is random
you know the scientists say it's random
but there's no evidence that it's random
or that it's chaotic for that matter
you know the Big Bang Theory
that the Universe originated with a big
bang billions and billions of years ago
well the scientists weren't there
they're just looking at at the heavens
and they're assuming that all that came
from there
the bottom line is
that we have to choose between
the Bible story
or evolutionary science in quotation
marks
and science that's been proven makes
many mistakes
in in the course of history
um if I could read maybe a couple of
statements from the spirit of Prophecy
um
I think it would be useful
the word of God is compared with the
supposed teachings of science
and is made to appear uncertain and
untrustworthy thus the seeds of Doubt
are planted in the minds of the youth
and in time of Temptation they spring up
When Faith In God's word is lost
the soul has no guide
no safeguard
the youth are drawn into paths which
lead away from God and from everlasting
life
the bottom line is we have to have a
settled faith in the word of God
by faith we believe that the worlds were
created and God made that which can be
seen from which would what could not be
seen according to Hebrews chapter 11. so
it's a matter of whether I am willing to
have faith or not
and without faith it is impossible to
please God Amen there's another
statement that I'd like to read in the
book education 128 and 129.
there's a really important expression
here
inferences
erroneously drawn from Facts observed in
nature now that's interesting in the
infer
by facts observed in nature erroneously
drawn from the facts observed in nature
have however led to a supposed conflict
between science and revelation
and in the effort to restore Harmony
between the Bible and between the Bible
and uh science she says interpretations
of scripture have been adopted that
undermine and destroy the force of the
word of God geology has been thought to
contradict the literal interpretation of
the Mosaic record of creation millions
of years it is claimed were required for
the evolution of the Earth from chaos
and now here comes the key
and in order to accommodate the Bible to
this supposed revelation of science
so you're never trying to reconcile
science with the Bible you're trying to
reconcile Bible with science right in
other words science is King
Bible secondary and rules
and you have to accommodate the Bible to
what science discovers but the but the
knowledge of scientists is so limited
it's change in the course of time so she
says in order to accommodate the Bible
to this supposed revelation of science
the days of creation are assumed to have
been vast indefinite periods covering
thousands or even millions of years
right such a conclusion is Holy uncalled
for the Bible record is in harmony with
itself
and with the teaching of nature
absolutely so the question is how big is
your faith yeah yeah and there are many
Christian Science scientists who take
that same data and say that it points us
towards God and proves and proves God
others take that same data and says that
proves that there is no God it a lot of
it depends on where you start absolutely
and what you're looking for if you look
hard enough you'll find what you're
looking for and in science as you
mentioned as you both are mentioning the
problem is what do you believe
The Big Bang Theory is it that is that
it's a theory there's like evolution is
exactly it's all a theory there is no
evidence they call claim their theories
as evidence but only is that it's only a
theory you know it's not proven it's not
and we know for a fact from the word of
God it cannot be trusted but that's what
humans do and so they look at the
heavens and they try to find evidence to
support their argument of course and
they create these ideas like somehow and
that's why I really personally dislike
going to these um even these museums you
know and sit through the presentations
because they speak of millions of years
and you know with such a an Assurance
Authority when we have not even you know
any records of that experience because
we are a new new Earth and New Creation
so it really it's it's absurd to be live
and Trust what men say but sadly some
people who are you know atheists they
will understand or choose to believe
something that is much more difficult to
prove than the Bible right so what an
interesting thing the main reason why
uh people want to reject the idea of
God a Creator a personal Creator God
is because if they believe that God
created everything
then we are accountable to him correct
you know the idea that we will be judged
by that God someday
it's very easy to get rid of God
and not believe that you're going to be
judged someday if you're the product of
chaos and you know natural selection the
survival of the fittest you don't have
to render an account to a personal God
who created you that's the main reason
yes yeah one origin of the species came
out they said finally we are out from
under God
and that was the motivation amen all
right well let's go to the next question
um comes from a friend Bruce and it says
the following question says my fiance
and I listened to sermons and read on
Sabbath
we're getting into a bit of a routine
what can we do
uh so I don't know if if that is that
interesting question I don't know if
they are getting to routine of just
reading and listening to a sermon
and if that is necessarily bad
what would you say Hebrews tell us tells
us not to forsake the sounding ourselves
together
if you cannot get out that's why
Ministries like this exist one of the
reasons right there is good solid
Biblical teaching that you can watch on
TV or computer but it is still better to
fellowship with the saints of God to get
the energy the Synergy the spiritual
lift that comes from getting up putting
on your clothes going to church singing
the songs listening to the sermon
reacting with the brother and sister
maybe staying for potluck there is
something spiritually affirming about
going through that that uh that process
that you you just don't get sitting home
now if you are homebound well then
you've got other Alternatives but this
is a bad habit that far too many events
find themselves in yeah we'll just stay
home today and watch it on TV no get up
and go to church amen Pastor you know my
wife and I every Sabbath
are caught in a rut
or in a routine
and that is that fortunately we're on
Pacific Time
so we're able to watch before we go to
church John Bradshaw
we're able to watch Dwight Nelson when
he was Pastor there
we were able to watch Randy Roberts
so there's nothing wrong with that but
when you substitute that for going to
church like you were saying it becomes
an issue so the the solution to this
problem is
get out get out go to church and in the
afternoon don't be a couch potato and
stay and watch six hours of some TV you
know go out and visit somebody in the
hospital go out and visit your neighbors
go out and distribute literature you
know go out in the midst of Nature and
admire everything that God created so
you know don't just get caught up at
home and be a couch potato and watch uh
religious programming for 9 to 12 hours
on Sabbath that defeats the purpose of
worship that is probably too much
information overload you might not
really grasp the best you know truth if
you stayed too long and so I think it's
wise but mentioned all right we have uh
time perhaps for one last question so we
can answer this one this is from
Alexander and he's from Cameroon Africa
what a blessing to have Alexander write
to us
and it says a following thank you very
much for answering my last question and
really blessed my name is Alexander from
duala Cameroon
and my question today come from the book
of Acts chapter 2 verse 1.
Acts 2 1 says and when the day of
Pentecost was fully come they were all
with one Accord in one place
on which day of the week did the
disciples receive the Holy Spirit
that is the question that Alexander has
for us
well if you do the calculations the Holy
Spirit was poured out on Sunday
you know if you do the calculations for
50 days after the resurrection of Christ
would be on a Sunday and so some people
like Pope John Paul II in his uh
pastoral letter Diaz nominee says that's
very significant because they met on
Sunday
but in order to understand this we have
to uh go back to the Hebrew festivals
where the day of Pentecost is referred
to and that requires us to go back to
Leviticus 23 15 and 16 which maybe one
of you could read Leviticus 23 15 and
16.
um which is referring to the day of
Pentecost
now be while you're looking for that we
need to understand that the Passover
pointed to the death of Christ
unleavened bread to his burial where his
body did not see corruption in the Tomb
and the first fruits represents his
resurrection correct and then from that
day on you have 50 days and you have the
day of Pentecost that's a chronology so
um what does Leviticus 23 15 and 16 say
and you shall count for yourselves from
the day after the Sabbath from the day
that you brought the Sheaf of the wave
offering seventh Sabbath
shall be completed
count 50 days to the day after the 7th
Sabbath then you shall offer a new grain
offering to the Lord you want 17 and 18.
no that's it that's it so
the wave Chief was waived the day after
the Sabbath correct so what day would
that be that Sunday what we call Sunday
the first day of the week right that was
the day of Christ's Resurrection correct
50 days later if you do the calculations
would be a Sunday again correct and so
they say well you know the fact is that
that proves that the church should meet
on Sundays for the worship service
however
when you look carefully
you discover something very interesting
why did the day of Pentecost fall on the
day after the Sabbath
for a very simple reason
because Jesus had to rest in the Tomb on
the Sabbath
how how could Jesus
celebrate the Feast of Pentecost by
pouring out the Holy Spirit
50 days after he rested in the Tomb
there would not be 50 days after resting
the tomb so the the reason why he
resurrected on on the first day of the
week Pentecost 50 days later is because
he had to rest in the Tomb on the
Sabbath now there's a significant day
it's not Sunday right the significant
day is the Sabbath exactly and and so
you know Pope John Paul II in his uh in
his pastoral letter D as dominant he
gave all this list of things that
happened on Sunday uh Jesus walked to
Emmaus with two disciples on Sunday he
appeared through the 11 on Sunday night
a week later he appeared to the apostles
on the Sunday again and then he says
Sunday the first proclamation of the
Gospel on the day of Pentecost the first
baptisms and so on so he gives this long
list
but the long list is insignificant
because the resurrection
marks that 50 days later which would be
the first day of the week
is only because Jesus rested in the Tomb
on the Sabbath day in in fulfillment of
the Mana episode where Manna did not
fall in Sabbath and it did not see
corruption when it was saved from one
day to another yes correct and that's
why the the it's important to understand
the link of the of the feast days what
they pointed to understanding they were
to honor the process of Christ as you
mentioned you know Dinah tomb I mean
dying on Friday rest in the Sabbath
resurrecting on the what they call the
the fresh fruits as a as a example of
him resurrecting and then 50 days or
right after that but obviously this is
really something that supports the the
importance that the Sabbath has in the
Plan of Salvation and how Christ would
honor the Sabbath even in death so yeah
the bottom line is that Jesus
resurrected on Sunday not to say that
Sunday is sacred right he resurrected on
Sunday because he had the rest of the
Zuma Sabbath I mean it's not it's not
rocket science the significant day is
the Sabbath he rested in the Tomb and
then when would he resurrect next day
but very next day of course so the
significant day is not Sunday no it's
the Sabbath when he rests from his works
of redemption like at creation on the
seventh day he worked from his works of
creation and like in the future we will
go from Sabbath to Sabbath to
commemorate that creation new creation
of heavens and earth Amen to that
any other thoughts about this because I
think that sometimes we can see people
sort of
looking at these evidence to support
Sunday as a day of worship as a day of
sacredness but truly it's it's not and I
think that one of the things we have to
be able to present to to those around us
or especially the people that worship on
Sunday is the fact that the Sabbath is
relevant throughout all that experience
of Christ even through you know with the
disciples they never ever supported the
idea of replacing the Sabbath with
Sunday even though they had they were
experiencing these events so-called on a
Sunday again for them it was very
clearly that Sabbath was relevant and is
still a part of their experience in
religion is there any other thoughts you
may have about this no the the the over
emphasis on Sunday is just a distraction
the Common Thread through all of this is
resting on Sabbath from creation through
Redemption is wrestling on Sabbath yeah
because life it didn't on the Sabbath we
enter his rest yes you can't enter into
Christ's rest at creation another day
other than the Sabbath because as they
arrested you can't enter his rest in
Redemption another day then the Sabbath
because that's they arrested in the
future you cannot enter God's rest
except on the seventh day because that's
the sign of the creation of new heavens
and new earth right it has to be the
very day you know and I might mention we
just have a few seconds left that uh you
know we can the Sabbath
Sunday cannot commemorate creation
no because create because the
commemoration of creation was on the
Sabbath that wasn't on Sunday exactly
you know my wife and I celebrate our
anniversary every 23rd of December why
do we do it December 23 because it's
rooted in history that was the day when
the event happened why do we keep the
Sabbath because it's rooted in history
that's the day that God that Jesus Jesus
rested and so you cannot
celebrate creation on Sunday because
that's not when Jesus rested
beginning of the next week
well we certainly thank you for allowing
us to share with you from the word of
God the answers to your questions we
pray that you will continue to study and
to find yourself approved before the
Lord by being a good student of the
Bible may God bless you see you next
time God bless you
thank you
[Music]
foreign